hey what's up guys my name is zacherno
welcome back to devlog monday
a little late this week so as usual this
is like the little series we have here
on youtube where we just take a look at
what
i've been doing with my life for the
last week and more importantly what
hazel has been doing
over the last week and all the various
progress we've made now i usually leave
this to the end but i thought that it
made more sense to kind of start with
saying this hazel is a game engine that
i'm working on with a bunch of
volunteers as well
from the community the reason that i'm
able to work so much on this game engine
is because of all the lovely patrons who
help
support the development of hazel without
those
patrons this would not really exist at
least not in the same way that it does
now it would probably be a hobby project
i'd probably still be working on an
engine because i just love game
engines but it would not be at the stage
that it is at now and it wouldn't be as
serious as it is from this project
itself stems a lot of
other stuff i mean the game engine
series on youtube
is based on this kind of technology that
we're developing here
a bunch of other kind of tutorials and
educational resources come out of this
as well so i just want to start by
saying
a huge thank you to everyone who is
involved with the support of hazel
and my patreon patreon.com where you can
go to help support this project
and everything else i do on youtube and
you'll get access to
all of hazel's source code and also be
able to keep in touch
with the community that's almost like a
little sponsorship announcement
sponsored by
you guys okay so what did i do over the
last
week um well basically if you recall
what happened last ever
i'll leave a link up there it's actually
quite a journey quite an interesting
story so i recommend that you definitely
check that out if you haven't already
basically we were in the middle of like
optimizing vulcan trying to work out
some kind of issues we actually had with
the vulcan renderer
and since we were still kind of stuck in
vulcan land more or less i thought it
would be a good opportunity to basically
just cross off some other items from my
list
that i wanted to get done and kind of
like the lower level kind of
architecture of hazel's renderer because
there was some stuff building up that i
knew
that i kind of uh you know like when i
build hazel i don't
like you know i've worked on large game
engines before like i know how they
work and i know like the hazel is not
like them necessarily i know that hazel
can't be like them necessarily because
traditionally a game engine like
frostbite or unreal engine
is developed by like thousands of
engineers over a very long period of
time more than a decade
probably like more than two decades and
in unreal engines case it's probably
almost three decades
23 years ago 1998
that's when unreal engine was first
released so anyway my point is just that
there are certain kind of things that i
there are certain compromises i have to
make obviously because we just simply
don't have the time or the resources to
try and
to try and try and be one of the big
engines
and that's not really the goal of hazel
anyway so sometimes i deliberately do
things in a way that i know is going to
have to change
because it will kind of provide
potentially an
easier path for people learning how game
engines work because
most of the people interested in hazel
are kind of interested in it because
they want to learn more about game
engines and also because it's just going
to be quicker to implement
and it's going to give us more results
faster so
one of the things that i did in the
beginning basically was i wrote
like the whole renderer in a way that is
really only designed
for a single kind of i guess almost
atomic render operation meaning that
like you begin your rendering
you render your entire like scene to
like some kind of frame buffer
there's always an end goal there's
always like an end kind of resulting
image from that render
and that's kind of it and then you begin
the next frame and that's all fine
but what if we want to do something a
little bit different what if we want to
actually render
two scenes at once or something like
that right why would you want to do that
well recently actually we had a use case
for this
we wanted to be able to uh basically
have a sort of asset viewer so
we wanted to be able to double click on
like a mesh like an fbx file inside the
content browser inside hazel and then
have it open in like a window
where you could actually look at the
model the mesh itself and see like for
example what sub meshes it consists of
what materials it has
how many vertices it has in just
detailed information about that actual
model
and then you'd actually be able to for
example be like oh well i don't want
these sub meshes i just want these sub
meshes i want to basically like asset
import settings we wanted to have
something like that
unreal engine basically has something
like that you can just like
in in the content browser double click
on like a mesh file and it will open
like in a separate viewport that you can
you know play around with as we kind of
start using
hazel more and more for actual like
development work so in other words
making an actual game with it you kind
of come across all of these features
that you want to have and that was one
of them now that
feature itself is actually
like really quite nice to architect
properly because if you do you can
really take advantage of falcon so in
vulcan for example you can actually
multi-thread the cpu side of of things
in opengl you have to execute all of
your render commands on a single thread
in vulcan you don't in vulcan instead
you basically construct these command
buffers
and then you can like cue up those
command buffers on the gpu and you can
do all of that
from different threads so in other words
i could literally if i set this up
properly
i could have four different views four
different scenes
and i could actually create all of those
kind of render command buffers
on separate threads at the same time
using my different cpu cores now of
course for like something like a mesh
viewer
technically speaking you don't really
need to like
reconstruct your command buffers a model
viewer is actually a perfect example of
where you can just
keep resubmitting the exact same command
buffer to like your
you know to your graphics card basically
through vulkan because nothing's
changing i mean the camera is moving but
that's fine it's just a uniform buffer
everything else is kind of fine whereas
in an actual like game in an actual
real scene rendering you usually will
have to like reconstruct
most of your command buffers every frame
because stuff is so dynamic anyway long
story short because i feel like this
isn't dragging on
a little bit i re-architected the entire
like
rendering kind of application side of
hazel so that we could actually support
rendering multiple scenes at the same
time and that's kind of what we do now
so let's take a look at the new kind of
like asset viewer i guess in hazel and
what it looks like so far so basically
um this is just like okay let's actually
load something maybe so that it looks a
little bit more legit so i'm just going
to go ahead and drag in
this little uh sponsor scene over here
we'll see what that looks like
this is just like a scene um it's pretty
uh
pretty straightforward it's just here to
kind of serve as a backdrop
okay so over here in the meshes
directory uh we've got this like sphere
one am fbx so let's go ahead and double
click on that and then when i double
click on it you can see it opens in this
kind of
extremely early work in progress asset
viewer
um and we have this i'm still playing
around with like the i'm going docking
layout and everything but we have this
um
properties panel that basically just
shows all of the different sub meshes
inside it
and then the idea from this is going to
be you can pick what you want you can
pick what you want for rendering you can
pick what you want for like physics
and then you can actually create like a
mesh from this actual
mesh asset and that's basically going to
kind of serve as like a view
i guess into the actual mesh asset file
because
there are a lot of cases in which you
don't really need potentially
every sub mesh or you want to actually
change some of the import settings
so that's kind of how that works um and
then you can see that this is basically
just a viewport
that you can um view your mesh in
and this is still functional this is
still there um and so is this
so let's go ahead and like i mean what
else do we have cube one m
we've got um cube scene over here as
well
now this itself is an actual scene right
so we have
actual kind of um we this is actually
running like
hazel's entire normal scene setup so
it's got like an empty component system
we've got um as you can see we've got a
dynamic sky here that's just generated
pray from sky model
um we've got like a directional light as
well so all of this stuff is working we
actually i think we do have shadows i
think the
the shadow settings are just kind of set
incorrectly okay that's better i just
fixed up some of the shadow settings so
we actually do have like shadows and
everything in here
um and uh yeah i mean every time you
basically open one of these
i think that's just an absurdly large
model that we can't scale down yet
but basically every time you double
click on one of these to open them so
first of all we still retain them all
here so you can switch between them
um let's maybe open actually let's just
open this sponsor model i think that
will be
a little bit better it loaded instantly
because it's already
like inside the asset manager obviously
for this actual scene that we see behind
so basically if we take a look at this
um
uh you know we can see all the sub
meshes and everything here
it's only ever rendering what we see
obviously right so if it's in the
background it's not like taking out
performance or whatever
but also we can actually drag these side
by side if we wanted to i mean here it
looks a bit weird
actually i've made this i need to play
around with the docking as i mentioned
because now i've made this like
inside the actual
viewport of of this but you can see we
can render these side by side if we
wanted to everything's still running
everything's still live
um but it probably like a more common
use case probably just to have them here
i also played around with like the
usability a little bit because i want to
get this you know easy i want to make
this easy to work with obviously
so you can double click on the title bar
and it will actually maximize it just
like you would kind of expect from like
a normal window
and then we have them all here so that's
kind of
how all of this is working right so
every time you double click on one of
these
aside from just loading the mesh it
actually creates an entirely new hazel
scene an entirely new
scene renderer for that scene and
obviously it loads the model if it needs
to
so that's quite a lot of stuff happening
and you can see it's extremely fast
which i'm pretty happy with
now as i mentioned i really wanted this
to be something that would be as
usable as possible what i mean by that
basically is i would i would want to use
this as if it was like a normal kind of
application and so one thing that i like
doing often
is dragging stuff to different windows
maybe i want to inspect a mesh
while i'm kind of working on my scene so
can i do that and i spent some time
getting all of that to work which
basically meant making sure that i'm gui
like viewports
that are outside of the main window can
still kind of forward their events over
into hazel
so that we can like you know have the
camera move for example
so i'll show you what this looks like
i'll have to it's a little hard to see
like a dual monitor setup obviously so
i'll switch to a camera behind me
okay so if i was for example to double
click on this like sphere 1m
i can open it on this other monitor i
can double click to make it full screen
and you can see that this is beginning
to look
like an actually usable setup for a game
engine so this is kind of
i guess the stuff that i was working on
during the week to ensure that this
would actually be
like you know nice i guess to use
because that kind of stuff is
important as well now the cool thing is
sometimes when you're developing
something like i mean i had to solve
this
asset viewer like thing that we wanted
to have so i had to like
re-architect like the entire renderer
which i mean i i had this at the back of
my head anyway it was gonna happen no
matter what
and this was finally like the last draw
which was like because we needed to do
this to actually like it was blocking us
essentially so
i had to go ahead and finally do it
which is a good thing but sometimes when
you solve one issue or when you react to
something it has some other side effects
that i mean i didn't even
really account for because we can just
spin up like a new scene renderer
instance and then give it a scene to
render
what if we do that but with an existing
scene
that is already being rendered by
another scene renderer and thus we're
born
viewports we can have multiple viewports
theoretically that should work shouldn't
it
and so in about five minutes i just
added this thing
so we have like edit and then second
viewport i don't know why it's under
here but it's just
it's here for now and you can see that
this will literally just open up a
second viewport here
and then we can just go ahead and browse
this which is pretty cool so for example
i could maybe want to view something
like top down here
i don't know for whatever reason so
let's just leave this here
maybe this i'll pop over here let's go
ahead and like drag in a new object like
a sphere
maybe like into here and we'll move it
upwards
and you can see that i can kind of like
play around with this i mean i can
position it here
i can position it here the gizmo is
basically whatever viewport you've got
highlighted if you've got like a gizmo
selected
like you know translate rotate scale
whatever if your mouse is over
like a certain viewport the gizmo will
only kind of display i guess in render
on that particular viewport so i can
like move this around
drag in like a little cone or whatever
might be easier to move it from here
that's the entire sponsor i knew that
would happen let's go back to the cone
and you can see that we have this like
cone here that we can edit and
like i mean i think you kind of get the
point so having multiple viewports is
kind of cool again not like strictly a
requirement that
we needed but i guess this is kind of
cool for the future especially if we
kind of have like
four of these i guess have them have
some of them in wireframe have like left
top what else is there back
front whatever have those kind of um
like 3dmax style
i guess that's where i remember it from
um but basically have like a bunch of
you boss maybe some of them not fully
shaded because obviously this does still
cost something
surprisingly the rendering cost for
having two viewports is actually not
that
not that much greater i mean the
rendering cost itself is
is really not that much greater because
if you haven't noticed now there's
suddenly half the pixels
so we've made the viewport smaller it
still has to like render all the all of
the geometry from a different point of
view
obviously but it does work pretty well
um and i think that it's pretty cool to
be able to do
stuff like this and then kind of see the
effects i guess on multiple viewports so
yeah that's a pretty cool side effect
and of course this viewport itself you
can just kind of
drag it out and you can put it on a
second monitor which you guys can't
really see but i could put this
anywhere i guess and uh where did i just
put it here
um let's make this a little bit bigger
you can put this wherever you like um
and of course it will like work properly
and everything
will be great let's just put it back
here because i think it belongs here
all right that's better so anyway i hope
you guys enjoyed this little look at
what i have done in the last week
um for the next week ahead i have
actually like the next few day vlogs the
next few weeks
are going to be really cool like i
promise you guys like i don't want to
reveal anything just
yet but we are working on some really
cool things and perhaps the most
exciting thing of all
is that like in the works right now like
i have a game
that i'm working on that i will that
should not take
more than like a few weeks of actual
development time
this is not like a large scale project
that i'm going to work on for the next
few years
but i actually have a game idea that i
want to make inside hazel
like within like the next couple months
for sure
so all of these features that are going
in now and some other ones that i'll
talk about next week
um they're all kind of building up
towards an actual real project so i'm
super excited about that as i mentioned
in the beginning this wouldn't be
possible without all the lovely patrons
helping to support the development of
hazel
so if you would like to help support the
development of hazel and get access to
like the source code and hazel itself
and all of that stuff then go to
patreon.com
there'll be a link in description below
and thank you so much for your support
now i mentioned a lot about like
re-architecting hazel and like the hazel
renderer and all of that stuff
i will make a video basically talking
about how all of that works and what the
architecture is like i'll draw diagrams
and all that stuff i don't i don't want
to do it just yet because i'm like
i'd consider myself about halfway
through it so when it's complete
then i will make a video talking about
all of that stuff so if you're
interested in
that or anything else then drop a
comment below let me know
if there's something else that you want
me to make a video about and i will try
my best
to do that thank you all for watching
have a nice rest of your day and i'll
see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you